alors qu un peu polluants jacques fortin
cultive le sorgho depuis 1978
une céréale à la mode certes mais qui
existe depuis plusieurs millénaires
cultures vivrières en inde en asie ou
encore en amérique centrale
une céréale qui est bien loin d'être la
plante magique dans certains se plaisent
à dire qu'elle pourrait résister au
réchauffement climatique
si elle peut en effet se satisfaire
d'environ 400 à 500 millimètres d'eau
pour son cycle de culture
elle n'est pas à la céréale de la
sécheresse qui sauvera demain notre
planète
c'est une idée reçue ça il faut de l'eau
pour faire pousser toutes les blancs si
sûr à maïs on va apporter 150
millimètres d'eau 75 suffiront sur le
sorgho mais ce sera pas la même
production quantitative non plus en fait
le sorgho peut s'adapter à des
conditions limitant nos c'est par
exemple une alternative intéressante
pour en économiser puisqu'elle peut se
passer d'une irrigation indispensable
pour le maïs par exemple en france un
lieu unique étudie la diversité
génétique du sorgho le cirad à
montpellier centre de coopération
internationale en recherche agronomique
pour le développement ici 3000 variétés
sont passés au crible
on peut obtenir une production de sorgho
avec des niveaux de rendement très
raisonnable sans aucune irrigation dans
la plupart du territoire français un
peut-être dans le sud-ouest dans l'ouest
et même dans la vallée du rhône
alors que pour le maïs bon généralement
et il faut envisager entre 4 et 6
l'irrigation durant le cycle de culture
pour espérer le sorgho n'est donc pas
une plante miracle mais doit composer
avec plusieurs facteurs sa variété
son degré de tolérance et la sécheresse
ainsi que le type de sol sur lequel il
s'épanouit
c'est une culture qu'on arrive quand
même à cultiver en en saison estivale et
qui n'est pas de points sensibles aux
aux prédateurs comme les oiseaux parce
que cela c'est important par rapport aux
tournesols son gros défaut ce serait
quand même la récolte tardive en
indre-et-loire la surface sans sorgho et
de 3000 hectares avec un rendement moyen
de 58 quito par hectare vendu
exclusivement pour l'oisellerie et
autres animaux son marché le benelux et
l'europe du nord
son prix lui varie entre 120 et 170
euros la tonne